in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Lou and
Danielle are with us hey guys how are ya
welcome welcome where do you guys live
noon in Georgia
how will welcome to Nashville on this
eve of Christmas Eve
so you're rushing back home after this
to see Santa call so you got family in
this area oh we're heading home after
this okay wow this is a good day to be
traveling not oh my goodness
well welcome guys good to have you in
here to do your debt-free scream that's
right and looks like you brought the
tribe with you tell us about your kids
names and ages all right we got Hailey's
14 Murray's 12 willian is nine mm-hmm
and Brooke is five all right has Brooke
been practicing her debt-free scream in
the car yes okay cuz Brooke we're
counting on you cuz you got to bring it
here in a minute okay
good deal so how much dad have you guys
paid off eighty-five thousand alright
and how long did that take you about six
years six years making what kind of
money well we started out probably six
years ago maybe around 50k household
income and finish up now we're around 90
K what do you guys do for a living I'm
an engineer I'm in telecommunications
and danielle has been a stay-at-home mom
for fourteen years and she's just kind
of getting back into the workforce and
substitute teaching and that kind of
thing so go okay that's fun so the
85,000 does that include paying off your
home yes it does nobody pays off their
house I love you guys that's awesome so
that's why the six years yeah so tell me
the whole story what happened six years
ago started you on this journey and tell
me about the journey
well the journey actually goes back I
would say probably twelve years when
when Murray was born or shortly before
he was born
now we had always been tithers some
believe believers in tithing and that
kind of thing and but we had always tied
off of our net income and had been
challenged to tithe prioritize tithing
we're
you give off the firstfruits and so we
started a tithe and and agreed that we
should be on board with that tithe tied
off of our gross income and so it's
really after that Marie was born and our
expenses kind of went up and and as you
would expect and right is Danielle was
going back from maternity leave she got
a call from her employer that she would
not be allowed to work from home anymore
oh and yeah that's kind of what we
thought
and so our income was essentially almost
cut in half at that point because we had
already made the decision that we would
raise our own kids in our own home and
that kind of thing if it came to that so
that was a commitment we had already
made but you know I quickly got out a
scratch sheet of paper and looked at
what our budget was gonna look like and
it was it was pretty ugly Dave it was
probably about $600 a month to the red
and so we were really scrambling and so
you know we can really identify with
being a one income family and I know
there's probably pull any of those out
there listening right now they're in the
grind of it right now and through
circumstances that are outside of their
control or that kind of thing they find
themselves in a situation that they're
just scratching and clawing and so you
know at that time we were kind of
thinking you know god didn't you see
that you know faithful thing we did here
with the tithing you know you know
what's going on here
and so we were just really it kind of
put us in a tailspin and and honestly
within a couple of weeks I'm kid you not
the timing on this we got a letter in
the mail
and it was from my uncle in Virginia and
he had just settled the he was the
executor of my grandfather's will and
our my grandfather William Garrett Haake
had been finally financially faithful
with his money and had actually left us
a sizable inheritance oh my gosh yeah
and and it was just
you know we could hardly we could hardly
believe you know that the timing you
know the sort of the rapid succession of
events there but it was just such a
clear sign that that God's faithfulness
far exceeded our our little faithfulness
and response and so it was just it was
an amazing story and we just felt like
we had hope again we had you know we
decided you decide to take that that
found margin that you now had and I
guess attacked the debt server well well
what we did then we actually paid off
our truck several years early and that
got us budget-wise back pretty close to
being able to stay above water
and so we made a few strategic things
and yet like you said it gave us the
margin we lived on some of the dividends
of the stock that we inherited and that
kind of thing and it bought you know
back to school stuff and you name it it
just it just provided a way for us to
stay faithful little commitment that we
have made to our family and that kind of
thing
good very cool that's awesome and so you
keep scratching and clawing and a little
bit at a time and now we look up six
years later and you paid off your house
what's the house worth about a hundred
and eighty that's awesome very cool it's
paid for
yes yeah old people have their house
paid for right but no you're not old you
got your house paid for why because you
leaned into it and you just decided we
were going to take these steps and we
were going to scratch and claw and
attack this stuff and it worked for you
congratulations I'm so proud and beyond
that you know the scratch and claw was a
big part of it but in in 2009 is when we
were introduced to your plan and sort of
your program I had been to the catalyst
conference a couple of times and and
that's where we kind of got hooked up
with your plan cool we started to make
some real strategic decisions cashing
out whole life policies that we each had
we paid off our minivan we fully funded
you know like a Roth IRA account for
ourselves for that year we just did some
things like that we refinanced our home
and got a
lower interest rate we moved a an old
employers 401k and and pension plan into
our our own rollover IRA account it was
under our control just strategic moves
like that that that we wouldn't have
really known otherwise so when people
find out you guys have paid off your
home and they say how did you do that
what do you tell them the secret to
getting out of debt is what the
sacrifices lots of sacrifices mm-hmm and
that all that reorganization that lose
obviously good at yes the engineer here
he's he's scheming and scamming all the
time I love this guy man he's he's on it
you know did you notice the shirt - yeah
we have it all right
that's from catalyst I knew the shirt
was from catalyst - all right yeah very
cool you guys are so cool way to go yeah
you got a feel you gotta feel proud yes
I'm really proud of Danielle because
there's no way we would have done it
without you know her ability to sort of
navigate things you know financially she
handle you know all the purchases and
the audition at home makes home
economists look like yeah I can tell you
guys are you guys and you paid off your
house by the way man this is so stinking
cool man this is just awesome you guys
are fun well this is great
alright so Hayley Murray Lillian Brooke
are you guys ready just shake your hand
just shake your head
are you alright here we go alright Lewin
Danielle
$85,000 paid off in six years by the way
that's their house and everything
they're officially weird
they make fifty to ninety thousand
dollars a year and they did it they did
it count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
go brach I love it awesome yeah you know
what you were hearing there I heard it
did you hear it that was the sound of a
family tree being changed God's ways of
handling money intersected that family's
lives they believed it they bought it
they did it they executed and they
changed their destiny and they changed
their family tree and a little Brook
counts it down for the whole family this
is a memory it's a milestone market this
is the Dave Ramsey show you guys would
be so rich so fast and be able to do so
much not only for yourselves and for
your family but for others